Now, we reach the dreaded point in every game development cycle where we have to
start worrying about performance. Now, for a small map, the code we have will
work perfectly well, but for large maps we quickly incur significant overhead.
This makes sense, since what we're actually doing is drawing the entire map
every single frame regardless of what's actually visible to the canvas. Instead
of this, let's only draw the tiles that are on the screen at any given time.
This saves considerably on the total number of draw calls per frame that are
done which is typically where the bottlenecks are in high performance
applications. Now, to implement this, notice that we've added a new viewRect
object wihtin our tile map class. This object represents the coordinates, as
well as width and heighth of our visible canvass. To take advantage of this, we
have to modify our drawing function slightly. First, we'll need to check our
world x and world y values against the current viewRect position and size, and
stop processing that tile if it's outside of our viewRect. Next, we have to
modify our worldX and worldY coordinates so they take into account the view
rectangle offset, ensuring that the x and y value that they pass to drawImage
are canvas-oriented rather than world-oriented.